[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRASHANT YADAV: Welcome to the
session Building More Reliable
Integrations with G
Suite Reseller APIs.
I'm very excited to
host all of you up here.
And as the name
suggests, the stock
is focused towards
Google partners who
are interested in
selling G Suite
products to their customers,
and want to leverage the G Suite
reseller APIs to do so.
A bit of an advanced
warning-- some of the slides
might actually get
deeply technical,
so I'll try my best to keep
it more interactive and not
boring.
Starting off with a
little bit about me--
my name is Prashant
Yadav, and I've
been a software engineer on the
G Suite Partner Platform team.
And I was at Google
for three years.
Prior to this, I
was at Microsoft
for over eight years working on
large scale platform systems.
My work here primarily
involves with all issues
related to G Suite
Partner Platform,
and especially focusing on
the Reseller APIs and Reseller
Console.
And I should say on behalf
of myself and my product team
that we are really
passionate about how partners
are key to Google's growth
in this online cloud-based
productivity market.
And me and my
team, we constantly
strive towards making all
aspects of partner integration
smooth and as
frictionless as possible.
And a little bit
about the audience--
so I expect you to
represent a G Suite partner.
You're most likely
a technical person--
an engineer, developer, manager.
And your primary
goal is to make sure
that you use G Suite
Reseller APIs to integrate
all of your flows and to make
sure your integrations work
at scale.
And you really care
about automating
most parts of your
integrations and trying
to remove all aspects
of manual steps involved
as much as possible.
So this is how the
Doc will look like.
We'll go over the key
takeaways from the session.
Then look at the most
important integration scenarios
which partners face.
Then go in deep
about all the APIs
which you would need to
be integrating with us.
Then look at the
testing best practices
and what Google
can offer you here.
And then go deep into
the integration flows
and what other technical
points in each one of these.
And at the end-- how
to get Google support.
So just let's go over
what are the key takeaways
of today's session.
So first of all,
check out the new push
notifications that
we have launched
that will allow you to get time
notifications about the most
important events related
to your customers.
And then we'll spend more time
understanding the new Test
Reseller Console, which
Google has started
to provide for API partners
and how to leverage them
and along with them, the
best practices for testing.
And then definitely go over
all the technical details
which are very important.
And they require special
attention for partners
while integrating.
So before we go
forward, I know this
is after lunch, and in
the middle of lazy time,
and throwing a technical
session at this time
are not the right recipe.
But let's keep it a
little interactive.
In case whenever you have
questions on any slide,
just raise your hand.
So I'll try to take the
questions right away.
And if some questions cannot
be answered immediately,
I'll be having time for
question and answers later.
And I'll be sticking around
here if anybody wants
to have some more discussions.
So let's start with domain
integration scenarios.
So first of all is a new
customer provisioning.
Where it starts is,
you have a customer
who is ready with a domain
and who wants to buy G Suite.
What ends up in this floor
is-- you create a customer in G
Suite, you decide the
right G Suite subscription
to buy, get the
right payment plan,
buy it, create the
initial administrators,
set them in a working state,
verify the domain when you can,
and keep the customer in a
state that the admins, they all
can just log in to
Google for the first time
and get their email and
everything working immediately.
The next one is for the existing
customers the general lifecycle
even changes.
Customers might want to upgrade
or downgrade their G Suite
subscriptions, buy
add-ons, or there
might be suspended or
activated plan changes-- a lot
of activity for
existing customers.
Then the most important
point is understanding bills.
So two parts for this--
first part is
understanding how Google
bills for each and every
customer and subscription.
So partners are interested in,
for every customer subscription
created, when does
Google start billing,
how much does Google bill
for its subscription,
and many times when would this
billing for a subscription
pause and when it would resume.
And once all of that
information is there-- how
to, in the right way, bill
the customer appropriately
for all these scenarios.
Then another very
important thing
is how to react to most of the
unexpected events that happen.
So not every kind of activity
that happens on your customer
are actually initiated
by our partners.
Many times our
subscription could be
suspended by Google for abuse.
A new customer might,
when they signed the TOS
for the first time, their
subscription gets activated.
This is not in partner's
control when it happens.
And a lot of other activities
like on flexible subscriptions
when customers actually add
more users or delete users--
all of them have important
repercussions for partners
and how to deal with them.
And the end is whenever
a customer decides
to close their account or they
transfer out of their partner,
how to actually gracefully
handle those cases.
So let's go to the API
integrations, which
are the most important points
for all kind of integrations.
So this page goes into exactly
the primary APIs, which we will
always end up integrating with.
The first one in blue is
obviously the reseller API
as part of Admin SDK.
This is the primary API
for managing customers
and subscriptions.
The next in green is the
Site Verification API.
The primary purpose of this
is to verify our domain
which a customer owns.
The red one is the
Directory API in Admin SDK.
Primary use for this API is
to create and delete users
on your customers' accounts.
And then the one in gray is
the new push notifications
which we launched, and they
work via the Cloud Pub/Sub APIs.
We'll go over those in details.
And then there are more APIs--
the Reporting API,
which you can use to get
aggregated detail
usage statistics
for all customers, and then
the License Manager API,
which will allow you to manage
in detail licenses for Vault
storage and a lot
of other things,
and then Directory
API, which includes
every aspect of managing your
customers, users, devices,
groups, everything.
So push notifications--
these are very newly
launched notifications
by our team.
And it's available for
all G Suite partners.
The notifications are
delivered to partners
via the Cloud Pub/Sub API.
And these notifications
are actually
near-instant, real-time
events about your customers
and subscriptions.
Whenever something
interesting happens,
you'll get events for
all these scenarios.
We'll in later slides, go
over in detail how these work.
So this is how you can actually
set up and get your push
notifications started.
This is a one-time
step partners need
to do once in their lifetime.
And starting off
with the yellow boxes
indicate what you need to do
on the Cloud Pub/Sub APIs.
You first enable the project
in your cloud console.
You create service
accounts, which you'll
use for getting notifications.
Then coming to the blue box,
this is the Reseller API.
You call the Reseller API once
to register for notifications.
We'll give you back a topic
name, which you can use again
to listen or start a
subscription on the Cloud
Pub/Sub API and receive.
Listener endpoints-- you
can create push or pull
notifications.
Both of them work well--
whichever suits you better.
And this is-- again,
our online documentation
explains all of the details
on how to get it started
and this is the one time effort.
Now, let's go into the
testing best practices.
One of the primary challenges to
integrating with these flows--
you always have challenges
integrating with all APIs,
but what is so special
about these APIs?
So the first thing is that
these G Suite Reseller APIs,
you don't freely get
access to these APIs.
You only get one
account per partner,
and that one is your
production account.
And the most
important part of this
is every API call you make
has a cost implication.
So every subscription you
create, every order you make--
they will end up
actually getting
billed for those activities.
And if you're working with
annual plans, whenever
you do an activity
or an order, you're
actually liable to pay the
bill for the entire year.
So it's not very easy to just
play around with these APIs
while developing.
And the last part
is-- because you
have one account, it's
development activity, which
could have a bug or
inadvertently affect
your production
environment, because there's
one account all your
customers are on it.
So there's a risk
integrating with these APIs.
What our partners
done in the past
before we had the
testing support was they
used to test never
nevertheless on the production
account, the single
account which they had.
And they had an
arrangement with Google
where they would do some
testing for some test domains
and then send Google the bill.
And Google would
manually refund them.
It was a painful
process, but it worked.
That process, as
I said, was always
susceptible to accidental
bugs, which would actually
harm your existing customers.
The other option was to use
it old Reseller API Sandbox
environment for testing.
It did not work
with any other APIs.
And it was only working with
the Reseller APIs especially.
And there was no bills
involved with that.
But really because it did
not work with other APIs,
you could not actually
test end-to-end with it.
And not surprisingly,
because of those reasons,
no partner actually
found it useful.
And eventually we
just shut it down.
So apart from all
this, what still
could be the worse
that could happen
if you do not integrate well?
So just a question--
how many dollars
do you think an accidental order
can cause due to some coding
bugs on outside?
Anybody wants to take any guess?
Is it like $100,000,
$500,000, or more?
So half a million?
So yeah, the right
answer is $3 million.
So this happened
not very long ago.
Suddenly in our system, as
you've seen probably in movies,
you have some
back-end team running.
And suddenly they start popping
up some severe exceptions.
And some engineer is paged
about some special activity
happening.
This happened, and suddenly we
were called for the details.
And we saw a partner
submitting an amazing amount
of orders for us.
Initially, we became very happy.
Some partner is really
getting big orders for us,
but looking deeply we
said something is wrong.
And we saw that within
a span of two days,
they had submitted
orders worth $3 million.
And we got back to them,
and they looked at it.
And after some
time, they realized
that an engineer made a coding
bug on their live system,
and all the orders and
everything coming to us
was starting to be
in such huge numbers
that we got up to $3
million of orders.
So obviously, after this,
Google refunded them,
but the whole process
is just so painful.
Nobody wants to get to it.
And believe me-- the importance
of revenue recognition,
bookkeeping, how
refunds, billing,
and everything is made--
on our side also,
also, we realized
how complicated these things
are when we face these issues.
So nobody at Google and
our partners-- nobody
wants to get into
such situations.
So the solution we
recommend right now
is the Test Reseller Console.
So basically, all
the active resellers
who have a reseller account
are eligible for getting
these accounts.
The way it works is
you create a test trial
G Suite account direct, and
then you contact Google.
And we will convert that account
into a Test Reseller Console.
The domain name
for those accounts
need to follow some testing
conventions to make sure
that there are no abuses and no
overlaps with actual real world
customers.
How do these accounts work?
First, they're
pretty much exactly
like your regular accounts.
The only exception is that
for all your customers
you need to keep following the
domain name guidelines, which
make sure that you don't
use real world domains.
And then this account
is never billed.
All the prices for all the
orders you do on this account
are zero.
And this data, because
this is a separate account,
is totally separate from your
actual real world customers.
So there is no risk
to actually harming
your production environment.
And you don't need to really
clean up whatever activity you
do in these accounts.
Google will automatically
delete all the customers
created on test accounts
within a few days.
And we really don't
have any number
of limits of customers created.
So while testing,
there is nothing
you need to worry about.
So I'll go over mainly the
brief testing practices
as we would recommend.
So first of all is while your
initial development for G Suite
integrations, use these
accounts while you're
building your code
for the first time
and getting your
integrations ready.
Next is all the
individual developers.
They could be given a
credential on their account
for their regular activity.
So whenever they
are working on bugs
or writing incremental
things, they
have their account handy
where they can actually
make calls to Google and make
sure their code is working.
The third is whenever
you are actually
doing a live system rollout--
maybe for the first time or
every incremental feature
with Google--
do an end-to-end integration
testing of your entire scenario
using these accounts to
make sure everything works
and end-to-end.
And at the end,
this how we set up
regular, weekly or daily
tests running automatically
using the test accounts
on your system.
This is the most important
thing I can tell you
from my experience I've seen in
the engineering in both Google
and Microsoft for a long time.
This comes really handy.
Even with the best engineering
teams and everything,
if you have systems which
continuously keep testing,
you will always find out
issues before they actually
hit your live
production environment.
This practice has been
a lifesaver generally
for all big companies,
and this is a no-brainer.
You always need to
have a regular test
activity happening.
So how many people
use this right now?
We have been giving this
out for one year right now.
All the new API partners get it.
Even existing partners are
eligible to get an account
from Google.
We have over 30 partners
right now actively using it.
We have seen more than
10,000 customers created.
And as of now we see hundreds
of accounts being created daily.
So clearly all
the partners using
are finding it very useful.
So let's go into the more
detailed technical flows
right now.
First of all, to
understand the data model,
the G Suite system has
two primary entities.
The first one is the customer.
The customer has a
unique ID, which clearly
represents the customer.
The other thing customer
has is the primary domain.
One domain can be the primary
domain which the customer owns.
And then they can have multiple
alias or secondary domains.
They can have a lot many
users in that domain.
The second most important
entity are subscriptions.
A single customer can have
multiple subscriptions.
However, for a G
Suite, you can only
have one G Suite subscription.
You can also buy
add-on subscriptions
like Vault and Drive.
Subscriptions consists of SKU
ID, a unique subscription ID.
They can have plan
details, number of seats,
renewals settings, et cetera.
So let's go over
the detailed flows.
What goes through in a
new customer provisioning?
This shows what all integrations
a partner needs to do
for creating new customers.
The first boxes
in green indicate
how you integrate with the
site verification APIs.
Whenever you get a domain--
a brand new domain
which a customer
wants to sign up G Suite with--
you can call Google's
Site Verification
APIs to verify that the customer
really owns this domain.
This is very important
since once you
verify that the customer
really owns the domain,
Google services can
work seamlessly.
The next blue
boxes are the calls
you make to Resellers APIs
for creating a customer.
The red boxes indicate
the Admin SDK APIs.
You have to create an
admin user, create a user
and make it an admin.
And at the end you
create a subscription.
Once you've done all
this you're ready to have
the customer in a ready state.
Some of the key points to focus
while you're creating a user
is all G Suite customers
are supposed to have
at least one administrator.
So you must create at
least one user initially,
and that user must
be administrator.
This admin must log into Google
once and sign the Google TOS
before their email or
anything else starts working.
Now, this is not in
control of a partner
but the customer has to first
log in and get that activated.
The other site is 409 errors.
So if a customer comes to you,
and they want to buy a domain,
but they have some users
already using Google's consumer
services like YouTube,
Google Analytics,
those are considered
conflict situations.
And whenever you try to create
a user which already exists
using the services,
we do not directly
boot out the other user.
The important
distinguishing factor here
is that if you have
already verified the domain
while creating the
user, we will allow
you to create that domain, and
we will evict the other user.
Evict means we'll not
delete the account,
but we'll send appropriate
action item for that account
or get rollover into
the real Google domain.
Unless you have
verified the domain,
you cannot do that step.
The other part is
transferring a customer.
Not always all customers you
get are brand new customers.
Some of them are existing
and with other resellers
or directly with Google.
So you need to transfer that.
The way you do that is first you
check whether a customer exists
or not while doing a
Customer.Get () call.
Then you manually ask the
customer for a transfer token.
This is like a password
which the customer generate.
And using that password, you
can do a list subscription
on the customer and
insert subscription
on each or the subscription
which customer has.
You have to make sure you
do the insert subscriptions
in a single batch request.
And once you do
that, the customer
will be transferred
on your site.
Some of the key points to
remember for transfers is that
while transferring an
existing customer to yourself,
you cannot make
changes to the SKUs.
You must transfer all
the SKUs as it is.
And all the
subscriptions transfers
must happen in a
single batch request.
You need a transfer
token from the customer.
And when you transfer
to a customer,
you will create a
brand new subscription
with brand new renewals
and everything.
So you don't carry
over whatever the plan
was with the customer earlier.
And one of the key
things to remember
is that when you are
transferring customers
on multiple
subscriptions, you need
to make sure that
on your own account,
you're already
signed all the TOSes.
Some of Google's additional
services like Drive storage,
they require the
partners to sign the TOS.
If you have not signed
the TOS, the transfers
will actually fail.
Now, just to see how
notifications work--
whenever you get a new customer,
whether it was an existing
customer with Google
earlier or not,
you always get a new
subscription we just created.
The moment the
subscription is created,
our push notifications
API will immediately
send you a notification
via Cloud Pub/Sub API.
On the right, you'll
see in green the details
of the subscription changes.
If you see the bold
new event_type,
you'll see here a
NEW_SUBSCRIPTION_CREATED.
This exactly tells you what
type of an event was created.
And then based on what type
of event it was, in the red
if you see, there'll be
more specific details,
which will exactly tell
why that even occurred.
So testing checkpoint
here is that when
you have unboarded
this whole floor,
how do you make sure you'll
do integration testing?
So the first step is you
have a test set up ready
where you have the Reseller
Console accounts all the TOSes
signed, Cloud Pub/Sub project--
everything in a working state.
Then you execute your scenario
of creating a customer
within your flows, whether it's
a website or any kind of flow.
But that flow should actually
go through all the steps
like to get customer domain
verification, admin creation
subscription, et cetera.
And then, at the end, once you
have gone through that flow,
make sure you
verify fields like,
you make sure the Customer.Get
() retrieves an actual
customer.
Subscriptions.List () creates
the right subscription which
you created.
And that once a
customer is created,
you get notifications for
a new subscription created.
And the other notification
will be subscription suspended
because the moment you
create a subscription,
it is suspended until the
customer signs that TOS.
So once you receive these
notifications in your floor,
you are insured that all
the integrations with Google
are working fine.
And again, a
reminder is that once
you've done that, you
don't need to clean up.
Google will automatically
clean up the accounts.
Let's go to how customer life
cycle changes are happening.
Quickly going through how to
upgrade to a G Suite business
subscription--
what you need to do is just
call in Subscriptions.Insert ()
on the G Suite business SKU ID,
and automatically your G Suite
Basic will get upgraded
to do the subscription.
Similarly, downgrade works
exactly the same as upgrade.
You just do a
Subscriptions.Insert () on G
Suite Basic, and your
earlier subscription will get
downgraded.
Now, coming back to
notifications for this--
the moment you upgrade or
downgrade, again, you'll
get a notification from
Cloud Pub/Sub with event type
saying that subscription
was upgraded or downgraded.
Suspending a customer--
you can suspend
customers for up to 60 days.
The way you do is
on a customer you've
got, call list
subscriptions and suspend
all of the subscriptions,
or whichever one you want.
One thing to note
is that whenever
you suspend flexible
subscriptions,
Google will pause billing
the partner for it,
but for annual subscriptions,
they'll still be billed
and the renewal data is
not changed for them.
Activating a customer back
works exactly as the same calls
Subscriptions.Activate
() for the subscription.
Notifications for
these activities
for both of these
suspended and activated--
notifications are sent
with the appropriate type,
SUBSCRIPTION_SUSPENDED
or SUSPENSION_REVOKED.
And you will also have an
additional reason field
which will give the reason as
RESELLER_INITIATED, indicating
that the suspension happened
because the partner had
initiated.
Some of the important points
to notice about suspension
are that if you do not activate
the subscriptions after 60
days, Google might cancel them
or transfer them over directly
to Google.
Suspensions could be
for multiple reasons--
if the customer
does not accept TOS
for abuse reasons, if
their trial period ended,
or something.
But whenever you
call activate, you
can only remove the reason
with reseller initiated.
That means you can only
activate subscriptions,
which were suspended
by the partner itself.
I covered earlier
flexible subscriptions
are paused for billing and
annual subscriptions are not.
And one more thing is that new
customers that always suspended
by default, and the moment
they signed the TOS,
they are activated.
Going through the testing
checkpoint, again,
similar to customer creation
for these activities--
how to set up ready with all the
things, how a customer created
and subscriptions ready.
Then run your scenario
in your integration flow,
which ends up calling
based on each situation,
Subscription.Insert
for either upgrade
or downgrade or the suspension
or activation flows.
Once you do that, you should be
able to verify by making sure
you received the right events.
Pertaining to each
of the activity,
the right set of events must
be received from Google.
Coming to the important
area of bills,
the main events, which actually
cause Google to bill partners,
is primarily broken down into
where the subscription changes.
Whenever a new subscription
is created or the trial
subscription converted
to a paid billing starts,
if a subscription is
suspended or activated,
billing could pause or unpause
for flexible subscriptions.
Whenever you cancel an
upgrade or downgrade,
that will end up
changing the billing.
And then, coming to the
payment plan changes,
whenever an annual commitment--
the number of committed seats
are increased or decreased.
Whenever the annual plan
renews, or in the flexible plan
cases, whenever more seats
are added or some are removed.
And whenever a customer
decides or the partner
decides to change payment
plan for the customer.
And for all of these events,
the push notifications
are send to partners.
One thing to note
for flexible billing
is that every day the number
of current licenses held
by the subscription
are used for billing.
So the way it works is when
you do a Subscriptions.List ()
and you get the subscriptions,
the field license number
of seats at that time tells you
how many seats for that day are
being charged by Google.
The right way to actually
keep track of all these things
is arguably to suggest partners
to run periodical cron jobs
and fetch this list to make
sure they know what exactly they
are getting billed.
But now, once you subscribe
to notification events,
you will get all the
right notification events
whenever something changes
on a flexible subscription.
So you don't need to really
be calling Google repeatedly
for this.
And some of the billable events
which a partner cannot control.
The first one is, for a
flexible subscription,
if a customer goes
and accepts the TOS.
Not all customers would
accept the TOS immediately
after buying, so they would
probably take a week or more.
So in those cases,
the moment they
signed the TOS,
Google will start
billing flexible subscriptions.
Next is when admins
add or remove users
in the flexible plans.
Partners cannot control when the
customer administration can do
that.
And then subscription-- whenever
they get suspended or activated
for other reasons not
in partners control.
And then whenever a
customer transfers away
from a partner without
partner initiating it.
So notifications are sent
for all of these cases.
So if you listen
for notifications,
you should be able
to deal with all.
Going to just testing
checkpoint again--
how to do all these things
are same set of startups--
get everything working,
have all customers
in a flexible subscription.
Then in the execute
session you could
try logging to the Admin Console
as a customer administrator
and accept the TOS.
And then go and try
to delete or add
users in customer's Admin
Console either by the API
or by the UI.
But for each of these case, the
moment the administrator signs
the TOS, you should get an event
that subscription suspension
was revoked.
And for the users
created or deleted,
you will get events like
LICENSE_ASSIGNMENT_CHANGED,
which will indicate that
something about the seat
activity is changed.
And you should get the
new field immediately
and see the right value.
Finally, coming to a
customer off-boarding--
so how do you cancel a customer?
Whenever a customer decides
to either close their account
or to cancel a relationship
with a reseller,
you would end up just
transferring the customer back
to Google.
So important thing
to remember is
that Google does
not allow partners
to delete customer's accounts.
You can just transfer
them to Google.
The way you do is do a list
subscriptions on the customer
and, for each subscription, do
a Subscriptions.Delete () with
the reason as
transfer_to_direct.
And make sure you do all
of these as a batch call.
Once you do that, the
customer is gratefully
transferred to Google,
and you don't need
to worry about the customer.
The other cases
are when a customer
transfers outside a
partner without actually
notifying the partner.
This could happen if
the customer contacts
Google support to
transfer, or a customer
gets transferred
to another partner,
and they transfer away.
In these cases, as
in the blue box,
the customer just
initiates the transfer.
In the red box, the
transfer happens through,
and the partner
loses the customer.
And how the partners
react in these cases is,
they need to settle
the final bills
and expect Google to stop
billing them for this customer.
For these cases right now, we
are sending API notifications
using those push notifications.
So listening to
the activities, you
can get the events whenever
a customer transfers out
immediately.
We also send email
notifications in such cases.
So this is just talking about
all off-boarded customers.
Whenever a customer
is off-boarded,
either by the partner
or for any reason,
you always get a
notification for that.
Coming to testing checkpoint
again for this flow--
in your integration
flow when you
run through the
scenario of closing
in customer's account, which
goes to the actual Google
events, which need
to be called, you
should verify it by
waiting for subscriptions
and making sure the right
subscriptions are called back.
And coming finally to support--
if you have any
questions, in general,
Google's online documentation
has all the details
about all these APIs
and other things.
If you need a Test
Reseller Console account,
you can open a support
ticket with Google,
and we can help
you get an account.
And for any API you choose
which you're facing,
when you open a
support ticket, make
sure you get all the details
right, like the full header
and response details,
authentication methods,
your reseller or customer
domain name, and all details
so Google can appropriately
address this form.
So I'll be doing a
little bit to recap.
The primary things are--
so you can just contact Google
and get a Test Reseller Console
account, and follow all the
best practices, which I just
described.
And remember about the
push notifications.
Use these to cover
all the integration
holes in your scenarios.
And keep in mind all the corner
details, which we discussed,
which require special attention.